THEY'RE ALL SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
ALL THE AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED.
PRESENTATION SO IT SHOULD GO
QUICKLY -- WITH THAT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO HERE PORTANTINO HERE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
PROPER CARE HEALTH HERE HILL
HERE JONES.
WE CASKEY HERE CASKEY HERE AND
IS BATES IS HERE.
TO BATES HERE SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS.
AGAIN IT'S ALL SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES OUR FIRST ONE IS SB
SEVENTY ONE BY MS LEYVA I'M
CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURES FOR
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION AS OUR
FILE.
THE WARNINGS TO KAREN MEMBERS
STILL IN A TERROR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE NO
FILE ON THIS MEASURE.
GREAT -- AND SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVENTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB TWO TEN
MY MISS LEYVA ON HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES -- AS THEIR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THEIR OPPOSITION.
REAL QUICK -- COVERING UNIT
MICROBES ON BEHALF THE CALVARY
MUTUAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
THIS THIS BILL WE'VE TESTIFIED
IN PASSED IN THIS FILM POLICY
COMMITTEE.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TO PLAY COULD
HAVE -- THE THE THE PROGRAM SAID
APPEARS DUPLICATIVE FOR PUBLIC
UTILITIES FOR OF EXISTING
REGULATIONS AT AT CARP -- WE
WE'VE TALKED THE AUTHORS OFFICE
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TALKING.
AUTHORS OFFICE HOW TO HOW TO
STREAMLINE OR ELIMINATE SOME OF
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS DUPLICATIVE
THANKS.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE IS THERE A
FINAL.
NO FILE NO FINANCING NO
QUESTIONS SB TO TEND WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO BY MS JACKSON
ON PLANNING AND ZONING WILDFIRES
IS THEIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION.
IS THERE FILE FILE YOU KNOW FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX BY MR ALLEN
ON STATE MOBILITY ACTION PLAN IS
OUR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
ALL THOSE BILLS ARE GOING THE
SUSPENSE -- AND I'M GONNA MAKE A
FEW.
WE HAVE TO THE GERMAN SPECIAL
AND WE HAVE ESTABLISHED FORM FOR
THE REGULAR ORDER.
IT IS.
ONE THING I'M GONNA START OKAY
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
PORTION OF THE HEARING AND
FRANKLY THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOMETHING BETTER ON TELEVISION
AND ALL OF YOU TO BE OUT HERE.
FOR THIS. TO WATCH THIS PART OF
THE HEARING I'D LIKE TO THANK.
THE SENATORS ON THE COMMITTEE --
WITH ME FOR THEIR WORK TO GET US
TO THIS POINT.
THEIR STAFFSMY STAFF THE
OUTSTANDING APPROACHING
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ARE FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE. TO GET
THE EVERYTHING TO WHERE WE'RE AT
TODAY MY VICE CHAIRMAN'S BATES
HAS BEEN AWESOME TO WORK WITH
AND AS HER FISCAL STAFF AS WELL.
HAS BEEN -- TERRIFIC IN
COLLABORATION -- BELIEVE OR NOT.
WE AVE ALL.
REALLY BEEN GETTING ALONG VERY
WELL OTHER STATE SHOULD TAKE
NOTE.
OF THE BI PARTISAN COOPERATION.
THIS YEAR WE'VE -- CHANGE THINGS
UP A LITTLE BIT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A TWO YEAR BILL LIST SO BILLS
THAT WILL BE COME TO YOUR BILLS.
NOT HELD ON SUSPENSE BUT HELD IN
THIS ON THIS TO YUR FILE.
AND SO I WILL READ TO YOU THE
FOLLOWING BILLS THAT WILL BE
COME TO YOUR BILLS.
SB SIX FIFTY THREE BY MISH
CHIANG.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN BY MR GLAZER.
SB TWO FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER
HERTZBERG AND SB FIFTY BY MISTER
WEINER.
ARE ALL THE TO YOUR BILLS.
WILL BE MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH
THE AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY BY
AUTHOR -- PAY CLOSE ATTENTION WE
WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING MEMBER
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING LET ME SAY
THAT AGAIN.
WE WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING.
I WILL ANNOUNCE THE AUTHOR
MEASURE NUMBER PROVIDE A BRIEF
DESCRIPTION OF THE AMENDMENTS.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING WE WILL BE
POSTING OF THE HEARING RESULTS
AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN FOR EACH
MEMBER ON THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND THAT WILL ALSO INCLUDE A
LIST OF BILLS.
THAT WERE HELD ON SUSPENSE.
SO WITH THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SUSPENSE PORTION OF THE MEETING
OUR FIRST AUTHOR OP IS SENATOR
ALAN WITH SB.
THREE OFFICE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
COORDINATING ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
IS A TO PASS AND WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE [inaudible] SIX
ZERO THAT BILL PASSES SIXTY ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY -- WE REMOVED SB
FORTY THREE ON CARBON TAXES AND
THAT BILL THE RECOMMENDATION IS.
TO APPROVE WITH THE MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO UPDATE SCOPE FOR CARP
STUDY IN AMEND TO REMOVE CD T.
F. A STUDY REQUIREMENTS.
THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FORTY TWO SB -- FIFTY FOUR IT IS
TO PASS.
AND WE WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO NINE FORTY TWO
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
HELLO.
SB.
FIFTY FOUR HI.
HILL I WOULD JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MISTER
BRADFORD BRADFORD.
HI WILL PLACE THAT I'M FALL.
MOVING SB FIFTY NINE AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES TECHNOLOGY STATEWIDE
POLICY -- THAT IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE AND THERE'S A MA'AM IT'S
PER AUTHORED A CREEK REVIVED
CARBS ROLE DELAY REPORT BY ONE
YEAR AND MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
NOT LOADING BRADFORD.
PROFFERED AYE HILL.
WELL I JONES JONES I WE KOWSKI
HI WE CASKEY AYE.
I DESERVE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TWO ZERO WE ARE MOVING TO
SB ONE THIRTY NINE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS WITH
THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
SIMPLIFY THE COMMISSION
SELECTION PROCESS TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES AND THAT'S ON
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE A ROLL
CALL OF FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL WAS APPROVED ON A FIVE TO
VOTE.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE.
TO REPUBLICAN WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO EXCUSE ME.
I'M SORRY BUT I'M SORRY FOUR TWO
FOUR TWO FOUR CHAIR THAT'S MY
BEST.
FOR TO RICARDO HAD SEVENTEEN FOR
GOT WE HAVE A LIKE THAT IF
YOU'RE VOTING [inaudible] ONE
LAST.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVED SB
TWO NINETY SIX STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID IMMIGRANTS SEEKING ASYLUM
AND THAT IS A TO PASS ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO I HEARD YOU KNOW I
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE I
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ONE WE
MOVE ON TO MISTER ALLEN SP THREE
NINETY TWO GREEN CHEMISTRY --
THAT BILL IS RECOMMENDATION
AMEND TO MAKE THE BILL
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION.
PLEASE SUBS TO THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE SO THE BILL
IS APPROVED FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
MOVE ON SB SIX EIGHT SIX
CALIFORNIA PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
RECOMMENDATION IS A MOVE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES REGARDING THE
ELIGIBILITY OF GRANT RECIPIENTS.
RECEPTIVE TO THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL WAS.
APPROVED ON A FOUR TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NO -- SPI SCA TWO
ELECTIONS RECALLS -- THAT BILL
IS OUR RECOMMENDATION TO DO
PASSED IN A SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE SO THAT BILL
IS APPROVED.
ON A FOUR TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING.
NOW.
MOVING TO MISTER ARCHULETA.
SB TWO EIGHTY NINE MEDI CAL --
MILITARY THAT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND THAT -- WE'RE
GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL IS
APPROVED ON ANONYMOUS.
SIX TO ZERO VOTE SB THREE NINETY
FIVE ACCIDENTAL TAKING A
POSITION A WILDLIFE COLLISION
WITH A VEHICLE THAT TO DO PASS
WERE IN THE SUBSTRATE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB.
THREE THAT BILL WAS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE AS
BEFORE -- FIVE RECLAIMED ASPHALT
PAVEMENT LA COUNTY PILOT PROJECT
AMEND TO ELIMINATE THE MANDATE
AND MAKE THE PILOT PERMISSIVE
WE'RE GONNA STEP TO THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THAT WAS
APPROVED ON A SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB FOUR TWENTY ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
LICENSE SHOULD BEER AND WINE
IMPORTERS IMPORTERS GENERAL AND
WHOLESALERS.
WE'RE GONNA STEPS OF THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE SO THAT BILLS
APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS SIX TO
ZERO VOTE.
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT PUBLIC
CONTRACTS DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAM.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THAT
THERE WAS APPROVED TO PASS A DO
PASS ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF SIX
OH THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS.
SB SIX SIX TWO GREEN ELECTROLYTE
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN.
WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THAT THAT IS A DO PASS
PORTANTINO.
FORTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS
.
FIVE TO ONE ALL RIGHT WE WILL
MOVE ON PRO TEM ATKINS SP ONE
CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WORKERS DEFENSE ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OFF
WITH THAT.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
NARROW THE TROPHY HUNTING AND
LABOR PROVISIONS AND MAKE CLEAR
FINDING CHANGES
WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM SB FORTY THREE THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FORTY TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SIXTY SIX MEDI CAL -- FQHCS
AND RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
SERVICES IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IN A SUBSIDY TO
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE SO THAT
BILL WAS OUT.
ON A UNANIMOUS SIX ZERO VOTE SB
ONE SIXTY FIVE MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION SERVICES -- WE'RE
GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE AND THAT BILL IS A
TO PASS AND IT IS OUT ON A SIX
OH RIGHT -- VOTE.
PRESS BEFORE FIFTY ONE TO PASS
WITH THIS IS ON PERSONAL INCOME
AND CORPORATE TAX CREDITS REAL
BILL TATIAN OF CERTIFIED
HISTORIC STRUCTURES.
SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS A MAN
PER AUTHOR TO CREATE A SET ASIDE
FOR OWNER OCCUPIED QUALIFYING
HOMES.
MEANT TO MAKE THE CREDIT
OPERATIVE ONLY IN THE YEAR
SPECIFIED IN A TRAILER BILL AND
THE IT IS WE'RE GONNA SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL OF SB THREE SO THAT
BILL WAS OUT. SIX ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY AS AMENDED SB FIVE
OH SEVEN THE CITY -- UNIFIED
PORT DISTRICT TERRITORY HELD IN
TRUST IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OR SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB -- THREE WHICH
IS UNANIMOUS SIX OH VOTE WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS MOVING TO MS BATES WE
HAVE SB FOR SIXTY FIVE SENATE --
FREE NUCLEAR GENERATOR STATION
EMERGENCY PLANNING FUN.
THAT IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
AND WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE SO THAT
BUT WAS OUT SIX TO ZERO WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS SB.
FIVE FORTY ONE SCHOOL SAFETY
LOCKDOWN DRILL -- WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE THAT OUT A WITH THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADD A
JOINT AUTHORED AND SO.
MEDIA MEMBER INSTEAD A JOINT
AUTHORS.
UNANIMOUS WE'RE SUBSTITUTING SB
THREE AND REMOVED BE MOVING THAT
IS UNANIMOUS -- SIX SO VOTE --
SB -- FIVE EIGHTY NINE ALCOHOL
AND OTHER DRUG ABUSE RECOVERY
SERVICES ADVERTISING AND
MARKETING IT IS A DO PASS AND
WORK AND SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB.
THREE AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
SIX TO ZERO MOVING TO MISTER
BELL -- SB FIVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENT PROGRAM
THAT BILL THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO MOVE WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORS TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES.
IN THE MAKE PUBLIC FACILITIES
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS AND MAKE
ANNUAL ALLOCATIONS SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION AND SO WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB.
FORTY THREE THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A FOUR TO VOTE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB SIX
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
AVAILABLE LAND IS A TO PASS
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY AND IS OUT ON THE
SIX OH VOTE SB NINE INCOME TAX
LOW INCOME HOUSING CREDIT SALE
OF CREDITS.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
FOR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB THREE AND SO THAT BILL IS OUT
SIX TO ZERO WITHOUT A MEMBERS SB.
TEN YEAR PARENT TRANSITION AGING
FAMILY SUPPORT SPECIAL
CERTIFICATION THERE'S A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHOR TO REDUCE IN SUPPORT
SPECIALIST CATEGORIES FROM.
FOUR TO ONE AND SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE SB THREE
THAT BILL IS A PROVED ON
UNANIMOUS.
SIX TO ZERO VOTE SB TWELVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES YOUTH.
THERE'S A MEMONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION.
THAT WERE SUB TO THE ROLL CALL
FOR SB THREE THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS. SIX TO
ZERO VOTE SB ONE FIFTIES TO
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID CHIEF FOR
GRANT AWARDS RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
SIX TWO ZERO WITHOUT A MOMENT'S
SB ONE NINETY SIX PROPERTY TAX
WELFARE EXEMPTION COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS TO TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THAT BILL WAS OUT.
SIX TO ZERO MISTER BELL SB --
TWO ELEVEN DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION STATE HIGHWAYS
LEASES OR SOMETHING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THAT BILL IS
OUT.
SIX TWO ZERO SB TWO EIGHTY TO
SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR PAROLEES
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY -- OPERATIVE DATE AND
REPORT TO DATE AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT BILL IS
OUT SUBSTITUTING SB THREE ON
UNANIMOUS THE ROLL CALL FOR SB
THREE AM NATOMAS SIXTY ZERO VOTE.
SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE DRIVING
PRIVILEGES SUSPENSION OFFENSIVE
INVOLVING VEHICLE USE -- THEIR
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO SPECIFY
THE PROVISIONS APPLY
PROSPECTIVELY ONLY AND RECEPTION
IN THE ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY
THREE SO THAT BILL WAS APPROVED
ON A FOUR TO VOTE.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES THERE'S AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE CONTENT MAKE IT CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION.
PERCEPTIONS IN THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO SB SIX OH THREE BY
MISTER BORK US.
SMALL INDEPENDENT TELEPHONE
CORPORATIONS RATES AGAIN THIS IS
SENATOR BORDERS -- WE HAVE A
MEMBERS TO STRIKE THE COST
RECOVERY PROVISION AND WE'RE
SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT THAT WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX TO ZERO MOVING TO MISTER
BRADFORD -- SB TWO EIGHTEEN
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
ENFORCEMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE THE AYE. FIVE TWO ZERO
HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
SHE KISSED ME ONE SECOND
.
ALL RIGHT MISTER BRADFORD.
IS THE ONE WE JUST DID REGRET TO
EIGHTEEN IS OUT ON A FIVE TWO
ZERO VOTE MOVING TO SB -- TWO
FIFTY FIVE MINORITY -- WOMEN
MINORITY DISABLED VETERAN AND
LGBT BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PROCUREMENT THERE'S AMENDMENTS
PER AUTHOR TO INCREASE THE
THRESHOLD TO FIFTEEN MILLION
THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE AS
AMENDED.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT SIX ZERO SB TWO
SIXTY NINE ON WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS THERE'S A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL.
AMEND TO EXCLUDE SUBSEQUENTLY
DISMISSED CASES AND THAT IS A
STEPS TO THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB FOUR TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ HLLS
TIMELY FELLOWS PROGRAM -- THAT --
RECOMMENDATION IS A MAN TO MAKE
PROJECT CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT'S A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT FIVE TO ONE I
SP FOUR FIFTY FIVE FINANCIAL
EMPOWERMENT FUND UNBANKED AND
UNDER BANKED POPULATIONS THERE'S
A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR.
AUTHORIZE A THIRD PARTY TO
ADMINISTER THE GRANT AND STRIKE
THE 10% CAP.
ON THE BIOS ABILITY TO RECALL
RECOUP COSTS WERE SUBSTRING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
IS APPROVED THEN UNANIMOUS SIX
TO ZERO VOTE.
SB.
FIVE NINETEEN SB THREE SUBSTANCE
BROKE OFF FROM SB THREE BILLS
APPROVED AN INANIMATE SIX ZERO
VOTE.
I SB FIVE NINETEEN HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANKS THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PASS AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES ON A
UNANIMOUS SIX ZERO VOTE.
IN TUNING ON MISTER BRADFORD SB
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY FOR INCARCERATED
STUDENTS TO TO TO PASS AND A
ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE K <c.cyan>WI.</c>
THE BILL WAS OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB FIVE NINETY FIVE
CANNABIS STATE FEE WAIVERS FOR
LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAMS THERE'S
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE IT CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION -- AND
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE THAT BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A FORTY TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SEVEN OH FOUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS -- MORE
UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE SERVICE ACT
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
AND IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
BY PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
WE HOUSE HI.
BECAUSE HE AYE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JONES NOW.
SB SEVEN OH FOUR IS OUT FOUR TO
ONE SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE WORKERS
COMPENSATION RISK FACTORS -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AND
IT'S A SUBSIDY ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE BILLS APPROVE THEM
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO ONE DURATION
BALK ENERGY STORAGE PROCUREMENT
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
REDUCE THE PROCUREMENT MANDATE
TO NOT MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED MEGAWATTS.
AND MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND WE ARE.
I THINK MEMBERS WANT A STATEMENT
SO I COULD GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF BEING RECOGNIZED --
IF I DO RESPECT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS AND THE
FISCAL ISSUES THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH TODAY -- BE VOTING FOR THIS
BUT TO BE CONSISTENT FROM THE
POLICY PERSPECTIVE I DID NOT
SUPPORTED IN.
LAST YEAR WHEN IT WAS A
DIFFERENT BILL AND I DID NOT
SUPPORTED IN THE UTILITIES
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE THIS YEAR
AND WILL.
NOT SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR BUT I
WILL BE -- A VOTING FOR TODAY
BECAUSE OF THIS THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF IT SO THANK YOU. FOR
STRIKEOUT KING MR SURE LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
GENTLEMAN FROM SAN MATTEO AND
ALSO NOTE THAT THE STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT.
THE POTENTIALLY RECOVERING SOME
OF THE MONEY THROUGH PROCUREMENT
SAFE.
DEPENDING ON DETERMINATIONS ARE
MADE BY THE CASE SO AND PUTTING
ON MY FISCAL CAP I WILL BE
VOTING WITH IT ON ON THE MEASURE
TODAY.
YES.
AS SIMILAR AND CONCERNS I WAS A
A NO VOTE -- EARLIER IN THE WEEK
BUT WITH RECOGNIZING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING.
TO MAKE SOME CHANGES TO IT I'M
GONNA SUPPORT TODAY GETTING OFF
OF OUT OF COMMITTEE BUT WE'LL
TAKE A LOOK AT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FORE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING TO GET AN
EXAMPLE OF THE CONGENIALITY OF
THIS WONDERFUL COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THAT -- WITH THAT WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB.
YEAH THE I NOW SEE MEMBERS SB
SEVEN SEVEN TWO WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
IT'S AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK AND LIFT
THE CALL ON MISTER ALLEN'S SB.
FIFTY FOUR YOU COULD CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI.
THAT BILL WAS OUT.
FOR TWO TO ALL RIGHT WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO MISS CAVELL
EURO -- SB TWO THIRTY MISS
CARRIER THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AND WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE
BILL PASSES ON UNANIMOUS SIX TO
ZERO VOTE.
SB TWO NINETY EIGHT PROPERTY
REDUCTION THERE'S A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKECLARIFYING
CHANGES AMEND TO EXTEND THE
FREEWAY.
FREQUENCY OF D. S. S. REPORT
EVERY FIVE YEARS AND SO WE ARE.
SAYS SB.
TO NINETY EIGHT WE CAN TAKE.
ZERO ONE TO REPEAT UP BOTH
BOTTLES. FIVE CALL THE ROLL ON
SB TWO NINETY EIGHT AS AMENDED
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY.
MAKOWSKI AYE.
IT WAS OUT -- SIX ZERO MOVING ON
SB THREE SEVENTEEN HAZARDOUS
WASTE PROHIBITED CHEMICALS MEANT
TO MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION WE'RE GONNA SUCH
AS THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL WAS OUT ON THE
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE AS
BEFORE FOURTEEN SMALL SYSTEMS
WATER AUTHORITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE'S A
MEMBERS FOR AUTHORED REQUIRE
AUTHORITIES TO PAY FOR VALUATION
ASSESSMENTS REQUIRED THE
CONTROLLER. TO AUDIT EACH
AUTHORITY WE'RE GONNA STEPS TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE
BILL WAS OUT ON A SIX ZERO
UNANIMOUS.
VOTE AS AMENDED SB FORTY SEVEN
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
ARIEL STOW'S SURVEY THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO ROUTE THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION MAKE IT CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THAT THE LESS OUT SIX TO
ZERO AS AMENDED SB FIVE ANYONE
CANNABIS LICENSING PUBLIC
RECORDS THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS OR A SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL
FROM SB.
THREE THAT BILL WAS OUT -- SIX
TO ZERO SB SIX ELEVEN HOUSING
ELDERLY AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN A SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL FROM
S. TWO PASSES RECOMMENDATION
RECEPTIVE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT BILLS OUT OF SIX TO
ZERO WITH NO AMENDMENTS SB.
SIX TWENTY EIGHT PRUDENT DEL BY
PASSED DISPOSITION OF ACCESS
PROPERTY STATE ROUTE -- ONE
EIGHTY THREE AND WE'RE GONNA
SUBSTANCE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SIX
ZERO RECOMMENDATION.
ARE TO ME SIX TO ZERO VOTE SB
SIX NINETY SEVEN PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT SUPERVISION
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS.
AND WE'RE SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED SIX ZERO WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS.
MOVING TO MISS CHANG -- SB
THIRTY FIVE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
TASK FORCES A MEMBERS TO CHANGE
TASK FORCE COMPOSITION AND THE
REPORTING DEADLINES WERE
SUBSTRING THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT. SIX ZERO
WITH AMENDMENTS SB TWO THIRTY
NINE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
LIMITATIONS OF ACTIONS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT BUT WAS APPROVED. SIX
TO ZERO WITHOUT A MOMENT'S SB
THREE FORTY EIGHT STATE AGENCIES
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
STRATEGIC PLANS THERE'S A MOMENT
PER AUTHOR. TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
TO DEPARTMENTS AND THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB.
THREE ON A SIX ZERO VOTE WITH NO
WITH AMENDMENTS SB FIVE SEVENTY
THREE HOMELESS EMERGENCY AID
PROGRAM FUNDING.
WE'RE GONNA AMEND THE BILL TO
MAKE IT CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED.
SIX TO ZERO MOVING TO MISTER
DODD SB NINETEEN WATER RESOURCES
ST.
GAUGES THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS WE'RE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE CASKEY I
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TO ONE SB TWENTY SURPLUS
STATE PROPERTY NAPA VALLEY.
NAPA COUNTY REGIONAL PARK IN
OPEN SPACE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS THROUGH THE SUBSTANCE THE
ROLE FROM SB THREE THAT BILL
PASSES.
SIX ZERO UNANIMOUSLY WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS SB ONE THIRTY SEVEN
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION FUND
STATE EXCHANGE PROGRAM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PASS.
A SUBSTANTIVE ROLE.
SB THREE THAT THERE WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SIX TO ZERO WITHOUT
A MOMENT'S SB.
ONE NINETY FIRE SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PASS.
SET TO THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THAT BILL IS OUT. SIX TO WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS SB TWO OH FOR STATE
WATER PROJECT CONTRACTS THERE'S
A MEMBERS TO REMOVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FROM D. W. R. AND
G. P. A.. TO ADD REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE WATER.
COMMISSION -- AND SO THE TO ROLL
CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I BET.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL I JONES.
JONES I WE KOWSKI.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TO ONE REMOVED SB TWO OH
NINE WHILE FIRE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE WARNING CENTER WHETHER
MONITORING THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS.
A SUBSTANTIVE THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE TO THE BILL WAS
APPROVED WITHOUT AMENDMENTS.
SIX TO ZERO SB TWO FOURTEEN MEDI
CAL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
TRANSITIONS PROGRAM.
ROOM MAKE AMEND IT TO MAKE IT
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THAT BILL WAS
APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS.
SIXTY ZERO ABOUT MOVING TO A
CONTINUING WITH MR DODD.
SB TWO FOUR SEVEN WILDLAND FIRE
PREVENTION VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
OR SOMETHING THE ROLL CALL IT
SAID AS PROPOSED SUBSIDY ROLL
CALL.
FROM SB THREE THE BILL WITHOUT
AMENDMENT IS APPROVED.
SIX ZERO SB -- TWO FIFTY THREE
CANNELLA ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS FOR SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THAT BILL IS APPROVED SIX
TO ZERO WITHOUT A MOMENT'S SB
TWO NINETY NATURAL DISASTERS
INSURANCE AND RELATED IN.
ALTERNATIVE RISK TRANSFER
PRODUCTS -- NO AMENDMENTS AND
THAT BILL IS WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE
BILL IS OUT AS IS SIX TO ZERO TO
THE FOUR SB THREE FIFTY TWO
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE LICENSEE ON
SALES GENERAL LICENSES.
THERE'SA MEMBERS TO LIVE IN.
THE AUTHORIZATION FOR ADDITIONAL
LICENSES TO ONE YEAR AND WE ARE
SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO
AS AMENDED.
MOVING TO MR OSLO SB TWENTY NINE
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
THE PROVISIONS TO MINIMIZE
DISRUPTION AMENDED CONFORM TO
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION -- WE ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB FORTY THREE THE BILL IS
APPROVED FORTY TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR CALIFORNIA
DREAM LOAN PROGRAM GRADUATE
DEGREE PROGRAMS.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
WERE DOING A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY HI WE CASKEY
I FORTY TWO FORTY TWO THE BILL
WAS OUT FORTY TWO SB THREE SIXTY
FIVE CAO WORKS IMMEDIATE NEEDS
ASSISTANCE THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS.
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL PASSES WITH.
SIX ZERO VOTE SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE VICTIMS OF CRIME
APPLICATION FOR COMPENSATION.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
WERE SUBSTRING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE AND THAT BILL IS OUT SIX
TO ZERO WITHOUT A MOMENT'S SB.
FIVE TWENTY NINE TEN AND
ASSOCIATION EVICTION FOR BECAUSE
WE'RE AMENDING TO STRIKE RENT
WITHHOLDING PROVISIONS AND SO
RECEPTION RECALL FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL WAS OUT.
FOR TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW SB SIX TWENTY TWO
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES
MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
BUREAUS ROLE AND EXCLUDE STATE
HOSPITALS FROM THE BILL.
THAT BILL WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE IS
OUT AS AMENDED ON A FOUR TO VOTE
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SEVEN FORTY NINE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT TRADE SECRETS
REVERSE PUBLIC RECORDS ACTION.
WERE SENT TO THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB FOR THERE'S NO AMENDMENTS
SOMETHING THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
FORTY THREE THAT BILLS APPROVED.
FORTY TWO WHAT'S THE PUBLIC
CONCERT TO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW.
MR RISER -- SB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
ON CHARTER SCHOOLS MORATORIUM.
IT'S AMENDED TO CHANGE THE
MORATORIUM TO TWO YEARS AND
MODIFY INTENT LANGUAGE OR SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED --
FORTY TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW.
MOVING TO MS GALGIANI SB ONE
THIRTY FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE MOTION FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX TO ZERO SB ONE SIXTY TWO
CALIFORNIA CANADA VIRGIN SEE AN
ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION FINANCIAL
AUTHORITY SALES AND YOU SIX
EXCLUSIONS.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB TWO SIXTEEN CAR MORE PROGRAM
USED HEAVY TRUCK CHANGE OR
SUBSTANTIVE THE ROLE FROM AND NO
MA'AM AND SUCH AS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL IS PASSED SIX
ZERO SB FOUR FIFTY NINE CRIMES
RATE.
PRONTO CRIMES RATE GREAT BODILY
INJURY IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WERE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES.
SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE THIRTY
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
PREVENTION POLICY.
A SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS OUT -- AS
PROPOSED SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE
NINETY ONE INCARCERATED PERSONS
THERE'S AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE
REQUIRED INFORMATION SHARING
PROVISIONS PERCEPTION ROLL CALL
FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL AS AMENDED IS OUT.
SIX TO ZERO SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
MEDICAL CANNABIS AND ACHIEVING
MEDICINAL CANNABIS AND MEDICINAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS VETERINARY
MEDICINE.
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE. FOR THE BILL WAS
OUT FOUR TO ONE SB SEVEN OH SIX
PUBLIC HEALTH PULMONARY
HYPERTENSION TASK FORCE.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
SO THAT BILL IS PASSING ON A SIX
TO ZERO VOTE SB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE PERSONAL INCOME TAX GROSS
INCOME EXCLUSION DISCHARGE OF
QUALIFIED.
PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE INDEBTEDNESS
IN FEDERAL DISASTER AREAS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS OR
SOMETHING THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THOSE APPROVED ON A SIX
ZERO VOTE.
MOVING TO MISTER GLAZER.
SB TWO STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL
STUDENT DATABASES TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OR SOMETHING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
WAS APPROVED ON A UNANIMOUS SIX
TO ZERO VOTE.
SB EIGHT STATE PARK STATE
COASTAL BEACHES SMOKING BAN TO
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION RECEPTION
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB FOURTEEN HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES BOND ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PASS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL I JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE
AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TO ONE SB ONE FORTY EIGHT
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE STUDENT
SUCCESS ON TIME COMPLETION FUN.
FOR MEMBERS TO LIMóN TO
PROSPECT TO PERSPECTIVE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS TO NEEDY STUDENTS
WERE GONNA DO A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ZERO SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT A RENTERS TAX
CREDITS WERE MENDING IT TO MAKE
IT THE CREDIT OPERATIVE IN YEAR
SPECIFIED IN A TRAILER BILL.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE THAT
THERE WAS APPROVED BY A
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB TWO SIXTY FOUR ONE GROW RICH
TASTING ROOMS.
IT IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB.
THREE SO THAT BILL WAS OUT SIX
TO ZERO SB SIX SO SIX CEMETERY
FUNERAL ACT.
RECOMMENDATION IS THE PASTOR
SUBSUME THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE THAT BILL PASSES SIX TO
ZERO SB SIX OH SEVEN BRIBERY.
BARBERING.
WE TAKE A MOMENT.
BY THE WAY THE WRITING IS REALLY
SMALL.
I'M REALLY OLD.
SB SIX OH SEVEN BARBERING IN
COSMETOLOGY IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SB THREE WE'RE GONNA SUB TO DRAW
FROM SB THREE SO THAT PASSES SIX
TO ZERO SB SIX SO EIGHT ON
ARCHITECTURE TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THAT PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB
SIX OH NINE PROFESSIONS
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
THAT IS DO PAST SUMMER SUBS IN
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE SURPASSES SIX ZERO A
UNANIMOUS VOTE SB SIX TEN
CONTRACTORS LICENSING AND
REGULATIONS RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS.
WE'RE SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL IS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE SB
SIX THIRTY FOUR EDUCATION.
THE TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OR
SOMETHING THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT IS OUT.
SIX TO ZERO SB SIX FIFTY ONE
DISCOVERY POST CONVICTION IT'S A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WERE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILLS OUT.
SIX TO ZERO SB.
SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN
CAR IN THE CART CARNEGIE S. V.
ARE A ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION
AREA.
IT IS -- RECOMMENDED DO PASS
WE'RE GONNA SUB TO THE ROLE FROM
SB FORTY THREE IT PASSES.
FORTY TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW.
MOVING TO SENATOR GROVE SB SIX
EIGHTY THREE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES REGIONAL CENTERS AMEND
PER AUTHORED REQUIRED DDS TO
DEVELOP TRANSPORT TRANSPARENCY
GUIDELINES.
AND ACQUIRE REGIONAL CENTER SO
INCLUDED DISCLOSURE MEASURE ON
THEIR INTERNET INTERNET WEBSITE --
SO WE'RE GONNA SUB TO THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL IS
APPROVED AS AMENDED. SIX ZERO
MOVING TO MISTER HERTZBERG.
SB FIFTY ONE FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS CANNABIS IT'S A DO
PASS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL HILL AYE JONES.
WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
BILL WAS OUT FOUR TO ONE SB
SIXTY THREE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
LAW EXCLUSION STUDENT LOAN DEBT
FORGIVENESS.
THERE IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WERE SUBSUME THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THAT BILL PASSES AS
PROPOSED SIX TO ZERO SB TWO OH
FIVE BUSINESS LICENSE STORM
WATER DISCHARGE.
COMPLIANT WERE AMENDING PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY PERMIT
BARRICADE VERIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS IT'S A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE AYE.
THAT WAS [inaudible]
TWO OH FIVE
FIVE ONE MOVING ON SB.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA STEM.
ARE LAUREATE THERE'S A MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED TRANSFER.
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS. TO
SUBSTITUTE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
UNANIMOUS.
AS AMENDED SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
PLEASE BE TWO FIFTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
AND HOUSING PROGRAM HELPS
HOMELESS SHELTERS PETS.
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE
APPROPRIATION TO ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I PORTANTINO AYE BATES
[inaudible]
HI.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
EDWARD I HELL.
HELL I JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
IT WAS OUT FIVE TO ONE SB TWO
SIXTY FIVE CHILD HUNGER
PREVENTION AND FAIR TREATMENT
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES.
WERE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB THREE THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO
ZERO SB THREE FIFTEEN GOBIZ
PROMISE SOUNDS.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
A SO THE BILLS OUT. SIX TO ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY SB THREE EIGHTEEN
CONSUMER PROTECTION BAIL BOND OR
IMMIGRATION BONDS THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR. TO STATE
THAT THE BILL IS THE CLARA TORY
OF EXISTING LAW OR SUBSTRING THE
ROLE FROM SB THREE SO THE BILL
PASSES AS AMENDED. SIX ZERO SB
THREE FORTY TWO UNFAIR
COMPENSATE COMPETITION MARK
TICKET WEBSITES THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO INCLUDE
AMUSEMENT PARKS -- WE'RE SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THAT
BILL AS AMENDED IS OUT. SIX ZERO
SB THREE EIGHTY NINE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION RECEPTION IN THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE SO THE BILL PASSES SIX
ZERO AS PROPOSED SB FIVE TWENTY
ELECTRICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS OF
LAST RESORT RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO MOVING
TO MISTER HILL.
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO MOVE AS
AMENDED TO EXAM TOOK A PRODUCTS
AND MAKE PROVISIONS APPLICABLES
TO SPECIFY PRODUCTS.
PATENTED PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND
AND OTHER CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE SO THE BILL IS APPROVED
FOR TWO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW.
SB ONE NINETY NINE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OFFICE OF
SAFETY ADVOCATE --
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS FOR
SUBSUME THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL PASSES.
SIX TO ZERO SB TWO NINETY FOUR
THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
THE MOTIONS TO PASS PROPERTY
TAXATION WELL FOR EXEMPTIONS LOW
INCOME HOUSING. FOR SUBSTRING
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE BILL
PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB THREE OR
FOUR CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
PROSECUTOR JURISDICTION.
IN MULTI JURISDICTION ELDER
ABUSE CASES.
DO PASS IS THE MOTION PASSES
SECTION ROW FROM SB THREE SIX
TWO ZERO UNANIMOUSLY SB THREE
TWENTY FIVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
RECOVERY FOR TREATMENT PROVIDERS.
MENTOR REQUIRED DH CS TO CHARGE
A REASONABLE FEE FOR PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES. SIX TWO ZERO SB THREE
SIXTY MANDATE HE REPORTED CLERGY
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO PROVIDE AN
NARAL PENNANT.
PENITENTIAL COMMUNICATION
EXEMPTION -- AND SO YOU WALK
INTO AN IN AND READ THOSE FOR
YOURSELF.
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE WITH
DEMOCRATS VOTING I AND
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO PASSAGE --
FOR TO TO SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE
HEALTHCARE -- PRACTITIONERS ON
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT IS A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO SPECIFY
PROCEDURES AND AMEND TO DEFINE
TERMS AND STRIKE A SPECIFIED
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. TO ROLL
CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
AS FOR TWENTY FIVE CORRECT.
JONES NO WE COUNTY HI.
I AM IN NO.
TIME WE CASKEY AYE AND BATES NO
[inaudible]
FORTITUDE.
SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE AS AMENDED
IS OUT FOR TWO TWO SB FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN WORKERS
COMPENSATION TREATMENTS AND
DISABILITY TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ROLL CALL VOTE
[inaudible]
PORTANTINO. FIVE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HELL.
HELL I JONES.
JONES I WE COUNTY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE TO ZERO SB FIVE FORTY FIVE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
IGNITION IN.
INFLUENCE SIGNATURE INTERLOCK
DEVICES RECOMMENDATION IS TO DO
PASS.
WE'LL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY WE CAL SKI I
BUT WAS OUT FIVE TO ONE SB FIVE
FIVE ZERO PUBLIC UTILITIES
MERGER ACQUISITION OR CONTROL OF
LECTURE COLOR GAS CORPORATIONS
RECOMMENDATION IS. TO PASS WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE
AYE.
IT WAS OUT FOR THE ONE SCA THREE
PROPERTY TAXATION CHANGE IN
OWNERSHIP INHERITANCE EXCLUSION
TO PASS A SUBSTITUTE TO A ROLL
CALL FROM FORTY THREE SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
FOUR TO VOTE.
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SCA FIVE
TAXATION SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARTIAL TAXES -- RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AND RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE
BILLS APPROVED FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
THANK YOU MISTER HELL -- GOOD
WORK MISTER HUESO OR MOVING ON
TO HIM AS BEFORE SIXTEEN
EMPLOYMENT WORKERS COMPENSATION --
THIS TO DO PASS RECEPTION THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE SO
THE BILL PASSES FORTY TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO SB.
FOUR TWENTY TWO INCOME TAXES
CREDITS QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES WORK
READINESS PROGRAM AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE THE CREDIT OPERATIVE ONLY
IN YOUR SPECIFIED IN THE TRAILER
BILL SENT TO THE ROLL CALL SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY AS AMENDED SIX ZERO
S. BEFORE FIFTY SEVEN BY METHANE
GAS CORPORATIONS TO DO PASS
SUBSTANCE TO ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL'S APPROVED.
ON UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE SB
FIVE FIVE EIGHT COMMISSION ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICAN AFFAIRS --
THE IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX
ZERO SB SIX NINETEEN PROMISE ON
CREDIT REPORTING PILOT.
PROGRAM EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO DO PASSED BY THE WAY
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HELL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY FIVE WE CASKEY
AYE.
BILL WAS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO SB
SIX SIX SEVEN GREENHOUSE GAS
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FACILITIES A TO DO PASS SUBSUME
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE OF FOR THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO SB -- SIX NINE ZERO
WATER QUALITY TIJUANA RIVER --
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WERE
SUBSTRING THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS APPROVED BY
UNANIMOUS.
SIX ZERO VOTE CALIFORNIA MEXICO
INTERNAL INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS
PROGRAM -- IT IS A TO PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED --
SIX TO ZERO MOVING TO MISTER
TADO SB TWO OH SEVEN MEDI CAL
ASTHMA PREVENTION SERVICES IS TO
DO PASS.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE BILLS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY SIX ZERO SB TO SIXTY
IS A TO PASS.
AUTOMATIC.
AUTOMATIC HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ENROLLMENT IT IS A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL PASSES.
FOR TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW. TO PASS -- AS A PROPOSED I
SB THREE THREE ONE SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLAN
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHORED
CHANGE PLAN FREQUENCY AMEND TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATIONS.
THERE WERE SUBSTANTIVE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES
SIX ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB FOUR FIFTY THREE OLDER ADULTS
TO DO PASS MOTION PERCEPTION
ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE AND THE BILL PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY SIX TO ZERO SB FOUR
NINETY CAL FRESH BENEFIT OVER
ISSUANCE TO TO DO PASS MOTIONS
SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE PASSES -- SIX ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED BEFORE NINETY
EIGHT TRADE CORRIDORS
IMPROVEMENT FUND GRANT PROGRAM
SHORT LINE RAILROADS MEN FOR
AUTHORED REQUIRE PROJECT USEFUL
LIFE OF FIFTEEN YEARS MENTAL
LIMIT PROGRAM REVENUES.
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL AS
AMENDED PASSES.
SIX ZERO SB FIVE OH ONE ARMORIES
RIDLEY ARMY TO DO PASSED MOTION.
THE RECEPTION ROLL CALL FROM SB --
THREE THAT BILLS APPROVED THE
UNANIMOUS.
SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
MISTER TROTTER CONTINUING SB
FIVE THIRTEEN CALIFORNIA
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT.
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHORED REMOVE --
YES RESPONSIBILITY AND SPECIFIED
WATER BOND REQUIREMENTS.
OUR SHIPS IN THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THAT BILL WAS APPROVED
AS AMENDED ON THE UNANIMOUS. SIX
ZERO VOTE SB FIVE FIVE NINE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
GRANT.
FREE AND KERN NOW -- THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO MAKE FUNDING SUBJECT
TO APPROPRIATION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL ALL FROM
SB THREE THAT BILL WAS OUT. SIX
TO ZERO AS AMENDED MOVING TO MS
JACKSON.
SB FIFTY FIVE FIREARMS
PROHIBITED PERSONS CEMENTED PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY RETROACTIVITY
PROVISIONS IN TO FIX A DRAFTING
ERROR TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
HI WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT.
FOR TWO SB ONE THIRTY FIVE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE -- TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE
THAT BUT WAS OUT.
FOR TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO SB ONE SIXTY TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON EMERGENCY
SERVICES CULTURAL COMPETENCY.
OR SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT -- SIX TO
ZERO ESPYS ONE SEVENTY ONE IS IT
ONE SEVENTY ONE IS A DO PASS.
EMPLOYERS ANNUAL REPORT HEY DATA --
THERE'S A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB FORTY THREE THE BILL IS OUT.
OF THE BILL IS OUT FORTY TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO SB
ONE EIGHTY TWO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PLANNING AND ZONING WILDFIRES --
THAT BILL IS A TO PASS MOTION
AND WE'RE SUBSTRING THE ROLE
FROM SB.
FORTY THREE BILLS APPROVED ON A
FOUR TO TO VOTE SB TWO TWENTY
EIGHT MASTER PLAN ON AGING IT TO
DO PASSED MOTION.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THAT BILL PASSES SIX ZERO
SB TWO EIGHTY OLDER ADULTS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES FALL
PREVENTION.
THAT IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
AND THE SUB TO THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE BILL PASSES -- SIX TO ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY SB THREE FORTY SIX
DISTINGUISHED AFTER SCHOOL
HEALTH RECOGNITION PROGRAM TO DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION RECEPTION
THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX TWO
ZERO CONTINUING WITH MS JACKSON
AS BEFORE TWENTY FOUR TOBACCO
PRODUCTS SINGLE USE IN MULTI USE
COMPONENTS.
IS THERE SOME MEMBERS TO EXEMPT --
E. HOOKAH PRODUCTS AND IT'S A
ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO NINE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES NO BATES NO BRADFORD.
OFFERED AYE HILL.
I JONES.
JONES NO WE CASCADE.
BECAUSE K <c.cyan>WI.</c>
THE BILL WAS OUT.
FOR TWO MINUTES BEFORE SIXTY
EIGHT CALIFORNIA TAX EXPENDITURE
REVIEW BOARD TO TO DO PASSED
MOTION TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO BY PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES NO WE
CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FORTY TWO MOVING
ON THE SP -- FOUR NINETY THREE
EDUCATION SEX EQUITY THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO RAISE THE STANDARD
FOR THE NEW RIGHT OF ACTION.
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THAT BILL WAS OUT
FOR TWO TWO AS AMENDED.
SB FIVE FIVE ONE OIL AND GAS DE
COMMISSIONING CLEAN UP AND
REMEDIATION COSTS THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ADD
CERTAIN CRITERIA. FOR FOR DAGR
TO DEVELOP A COST MECHANISM
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THAT BILL IS APPROVED FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NOW MOVING TO MISTER
JONES.
SINCE MISTER JONES IS FIRST TIME
I'LL JUST PAUSE [inaudible]
BRITISH STRETCH.
ALL RIGHT OVING ON TO MISTER
JOHN JUST BEFORE FIFTY TWO WITH
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE'RE SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB
THREE AT BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO
SB SIX SIX THREE PROPERTY
TAXATION EXEMPTIONS.
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS TO DO
PASS MOTION AND THE BILL PASSES
SUB TO THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE SIX TO ZERO GOOD WORK
MISTER JONES.
MS LEYVA MOVING ON HER SB TWENTY
TO RAPE KIT TESTING THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO STRIKE THE
APPROPRIATION.
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
ESPYS SUBSTITUTING SB THREE THE
BILL WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY
SIX TO ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB TWENTY FOUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS ABORTION
MEDICATION TECHNIQUES THAT IS A
DO PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
SB FORTY THREE NOW BILL PASSES
FORTY TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW.
SB SEVENTY ONE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
CAMPAIGN EXPENDITURE LIMITATIONS
THERE'S A MEMBERS REQUIRE
CANDIDATES TO REIMBURSE ANY
CAMPAIGN FUNDS.
USED FOR RELATED LEGAL COSTS IF
A CLAIM IS SUBSTANTIATED AND IT
MAKES CLARIFYING CHANGES.
THERE'S A ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB.
SEVENTY ONE PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO ZERO SB
ONE SEVENTY FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION REIMBURSEMENT RATES
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY WHEN THE NEW ADJUSTMENT
FACTORS ARE OPERATIVE.
MEANT TO MAKE THE INCREASED
INCREASES CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLE FROM SB THREE THAT BILL
PASSES SIX ZERO AS AMENDED SB
TWO TEN HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
INSPECTION AND MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM.
MEANT TO REQUIRE CARP.
REPORT SKEWS ME TO REPORT A
PROPOSED SCHEDULE OF FEES TO
JAIL BC AFTER THE PILOT IS
COMPLETE.
THEN WE ARE SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE
THE BILL WAS APPROVED AS AMENDED.
FOUR TWO TWO SB TWO SIX SIX
CALPERS DISALLOWED COMPENSATION
BENEFITTED JUDGMENT THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES IT'S A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD OUR BRADFORD AYE HILL
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FOUR TO ONE SB TWO NINETY ONE MS
LEYVA COMMITTED CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAM THERE'S A MEMONS TO
REMOVE THE INTENT.
LANGUAGE -- YEAH
.
OKAY I SB TWO NINETY ONE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT FNANCIAL AID PROGRAM
THERE'S AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT'S A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT FOUR TO ONE SB
THREE TWELVE ENTERING SERVICE
DOG ASSISTANCE IT'S A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OR DO PASSED
MOTION ROLL CALL PERCEPTION ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL WAS
APPROVED. SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR BECAUSE MEDIC
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENT
RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TO DO PASSED
MOTION FOR SUBSTANCE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB.
FORTY THREE THE BILL WAS
APPROVED FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB SIX
NINETY EIGHT EMPLOYEE WGES
PAYMENTS THERE'S A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES.
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED AS A
MEMBER MENDED. SIX ZERO MOVING
TO MISTER MCGUIRE.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE CANNABIS
MARKETING IT TO DO PASS A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED SIX
TO ZERO SB.
THREE FIFTY SIX NORTH COAST
RAILROAD AUTHORITY THERE'S
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO DELETE
THE REQUIREMENT IMPOSED.
ON SMART AND REDUCE PROPERTY
TRANSFER TO TWENTY MILES OF
RIGHT AWAY.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL WAS APPROVED AS AMENDED
SIX ZERO S. BEFORE NINE NINE
SCHOOL MEALS CALIFORNIA GROWN
FOR HEALTHY KIDS PROGRAM.
THERE'S A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE BILL PASSES AS AMENDED.
SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
ELECTIONS VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS
TO DO PASS.
SUBSIDY THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR TWO
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN PERSONAL
INCOME TAX PREVENTION OF ANIMAL
HOMELESS AND CRUELTY VOLUNTARY
TAX CONTRIBUTION FUND --
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB.
SIX SEVENTY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES AFFECTING PUBLIC SAFETY.
WELL TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
PERCEPTION ROLL FROM SB THREE IT
PASSES UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX TO ZERO SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
PROPERTY TAXATION VALUATION OF
CERTIFIED AIRCRAFT -- IT IS A TO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE IT PASSES. SIX ZERO MOVING
TO MS MITCHELL -- SB ONE FORTY
FOUR CRIMINAL FEES THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED A STRIKE
SPECIFIED FEE ELIMINATOR
ELIMINATIONS AND TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AMEND THE
STRIKE ADDITIONAL FEE.
ELIMINATIONS AND IT IS A
SUBSTANTIVE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL IS APPROVED FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW --
AS AMENDED SB THREE TWENTY ONE
CAL WORK SUPPORT OF SERVICES
CHILD CARE TO DO PASS.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB
THREE TWENTY NINE DISCRIMINATION
HOUSING SOURCE OF INCOME IS IN A
MAN TO ADD INTENT LANGUAGE.
THAT VOUCHER PROGRAM RECIPIENTS
RECEIVE A THOROUGH AND FAIR
VETTING WHEN SEEKING HOUSING
RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THAT BILL -- FOR PASSES
FOR THE TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW SB THREE SIXTY ONE
MEDI CAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION --
RECEPTION ROLE SB THREE PASSES
AS AMENDED SIX TO ZERO AS BEFORE
SIXTY FOUR CALIFORNIA DIGNITY IN
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH ACT TO
DO PASS STEPS TO THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL IS
APPROVED. SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE JAILS IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES TELEPHONE SERVICES
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO MAKE
TELEPHONE.
CONTRACTS PROVISIONS APPLY TO
NEW OR RENEWED CONTRACTS ONLY --
R SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES FORTY TWO AS AMENDED.
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO SB
SIX FORTY SEVEN HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCE METAL CONTAINING JURY
TO DO PASS RECEPTION THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES. SIX ZERO SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN JUVENILE POST SECONDARY
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION IS A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE THE
COLLABORATION REQUIREMENTS AND
TO USE.
NARAL ACCESS TO ONLINE COURSES
ONLY SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL AS
AMENDED PASSES. SIX TWO ZERO
MOVING TO MISTER MINING SB ONE
EIGHTY NINE FOR ORDINARY USE.
AUTHORITY DISSOLUTION -- THERE'S
A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO CLARIFY
OPERATIVE DATE PROHIBIT FOR A
FROM ISSUING NEW BONDS AND
PROHIBIT REVISIONS TO THE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PLAN.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THAT BILL PASSES AS
AMENDED SIX TWO ZERO SB TWO
HUNDRED SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUN THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION. TO ROLL CALL
VOTE.
PORTANTINO BY PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL PASSES.
FOR TWO TWO SB THREE FORTY SEVEN
SUGARY SWEET BEVERAGES SAFETY
WARNINGS AS AMENDMENT PER AUTHOR
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION.
EXEMPT DAIRY BEVERAGES PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR SPECIFIED
INDIVIDUALS AND LIMIT NOTICE
LOCATION.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FOR MASS BE
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES AS
AMENDED FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
BECAUSE BEFORE -- SEVEN MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENT BENEFIT COVERAGE TO
DO PASS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES. FOR
TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW SB FIVE ALL FOUR STATE
HIGHWAY ROUTE ONE RELINQUISHMENT --
TO DO PASS UP TO THE ROLE FROM
SB THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED
ON A UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN CANNABIS
CULTIVATION COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONS REPORTING -- IT IS A
TO PASS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
BILL PASSES.
FIVE TO ONE MORE LOCK MOVING ON
TO SENATOR MORLOCK.
SB ONE EIGHTY FOUR JUDGES
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS DEFERRED
RETIREMENT THERE'S A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES.
RECEPTION TUNING THE ROLE FROM
SB THREE THE BILL AS AMENDED
PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT OPEN FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS.
BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR
TO HOUSE THE COMMISSION IN S.
TEO INSTEAD OF SCO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES ARE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE AND THE BILL PASSES AS
AMENDED.
SIX ZERO MR MORALE SB FIVE
HUNDRED VETERANS EDUCATION
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
LIMIT THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE-SCHOOLS BASED IN CALIFORNIA TO
LIMIT. TO PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS BASED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BILL WE'RE SUBSTITUTING
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE THE BILL
AS AMENDED PASSES.
SIX ZERO SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
PROPERTY TAXATION EXEMPTIONS
PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE VETERANS AND
THEIR ON MERIT SURVIVING SPOUSES
IS TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WERE SUBSUME THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX ZERO
UNANIMOUSLY MOVIE TO MISTER
pPASS OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES.
SIX TO ZERO SB ONE SEVENTY NINE
EXCLUSION PLEASE ARBITRATION IS
TO DO PASS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX ZERO SB ONE NINETY THREE
NITROUS OXIDE READ NITROUS OXIDE
RETAIL SALES AMEND TO STRIKE THE
MISDEMEANOR PENALTY FOR
EMPLOYEES.
SO THE BILL SUBSTITUTING THE
ROLE FROM SB THREE PASSES SIX TO
ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB TWO TWO SIX WATERSHED
RESTORATION WILDFIRE GRANT
PROGRAM THERE'S A MEMBERS TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM CONTINGENT UPON
IT AND APPROPRIATION.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX TO
ZERO SB AS AMENDED SB TWO FIFTY
NINE FARMING OF JUSTICE CRIME
STATISTICS REPORTING THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO APPLY.
REQUIREMENTS REPORT WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE DATA AND
WE'RE SUB ZERO FROM SB THREE THE
BILL PASSES SIX ZERO AS AMENDED
SB.
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN COMMISSION ON
STATE MANDATES TEST CLAIM FILING
DATE A RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASS UP TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX TWO ZERO MOVING TO DOCTOR
PAN.
SB SIXTY FIVE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
IT'S TO PASS SUBSTITUTE SB THE
ROLE FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL PASSES.
FOR TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW SB ONE FIFTY FOR MEDI CAL
RESTORATIVE DENTAL SERVICES. TO
DO PASS.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE BILL PASSES UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX ZERO SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
MINIMUM ESSENTIAL COVERAGE TO DO
PASS AS SUBJECT TO THE ROLE FROM
FORT SB.
FORTY THREE BILL PASSES FORTY
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING.
NO SB TWO SEVENTY SIX I MEAN
IMMUNIZATIONS MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY WHEN THE MEDICAL
EXEMPTION REQUEST FORMS MAY BE
SUBMITTED.
AND THAT CDP H. IS NOT REQUIRED
TO REVIEW OR PROOF PREVIOUSLY
GRANTED EXEMPTIONS AS SPECIFIED
ON OUR TWO SEVEN TWO THREE
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL'S PROOF.
FORTY TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING APPROVED AS AMENDED WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB THREE
SIXTY THREE WORK FOR SAFETY. TO
PASS.
WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX TO
ZERO SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE TRAINING.
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID --
WERE MENDING THERE'S A MEMBERS
MAKE REQUIREMENT CONTINGENT UPON
AN APPROPRIATION.
AND WE'RE STEPS TO THE ROLE OF
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX ZERO AS AMENDED -- SB FIVE
OH THREE MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
PLAN -- IT IS A TO PASS UP TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE BUT
WAS APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE TWELVE LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS --
IT'S A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY BECAUSE K
<c.cyan>WI.</c>
THOSE OUT -- FIVE TO ONE SB FIVE
TWELVE LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
AS I'M SURE ISN'T REGISTERED OUR
YEAH.
I JUST AT FIVE TWELVE SO THAT
WAS.
FIVE TO ONE THE PAST TIME.
RIGHT FIVE TWO ONE OKAY SO FIVE
SB FIVE FIVE SIX THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO NARROW THE BILL SCOPE.
AND THAT IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL.
HILL AYE JONES RIGHT JONES I WE
CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB SIX SIX ZERO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELORS MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY THE DEFINITION
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELORS AND
AMANDA SPECIFIED THAT THE RATIO
IS A GOAL.
AND THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED OR SUBSUME THE ROLE.
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX TO
ZERO AS AMENDED.
MOVING ON TO ME CENTER
PORTANTINO SB SEVEN STATE
HIGHWAY ROUTE SEVEN TEN THERE'S
A MEMBERS FOR AUTHOR TO PROHIBIT
RENT INCREASES FOR SPECIFIED
TENANTS IN TWO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYEBRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
WE CASKEY HI BECAUSE K <c.cyan>WI.</c>
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO AS AMENDED
SB SIXTY ONE FIREARMS TRANSFERS
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR
EXTEND THE PROHIBITION TO EXEMPT
PERSONS UNDER.
TWENTY ONE RECEPTION THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL PASSES AS AMENDED FORTY TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW --
SB EIGHTY SIX SCHOOL LOCKDOWN
DRILLS -- IT'S A DO PASS
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY. SIX TO ZERO SB ONE
SIXTY THREE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PERVASIVE DEVELOPMENT DISORDER
AUTISM THERE'S A MEMBERS TO
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT.
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
RECEPTION ROLE MUST BE FORTY
THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR TWO
TWO AS AMENDED SB ONE SEVENTY
TWO FIREARMS.
IT'S A DO PASS WERESTEPS TO THE
pAPPROVED FOR TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB TWO
SEVENTEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND TKA.
EXPANSION THERE'S A MEMBERS TO
MAKE THE BILL PROVISIONS
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION
FOR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES
SIX TO ZERO AS AMENDED SB.
THREE OH TO INTERNATIONAL TRADE
INVESTMENT OFFICE FOR THE
REPUBLIC OF ARMENIA IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO PASSED SUB TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX ZERO
THREE THREE TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE
ATTENDANCE SCHOOL START TIME IS
TO DO PASS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO.
BY PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY WE COUNTY I
THE BILL PASSES.
FIVE TO ONE SB THREE FORTY NINE
AND MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX TO DO
PASS.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE PASSES UNANIMOUSLY.
SIX TO ZERO SB THREE SEVENTY SIX
FIREARM TRANSFERS MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED A CORPORATE CROSS
REFERENCES.
IT'S A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES FORTY TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO SB.
FOUR FOUR FIVE ALCOHOL AND DRUG
TREATMENT YOUTH -- STEPS TO THE
ROLE FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES. SIX TO ZERO TO DO PASSED
MOTIONAS BEFORE EIGHTY FOUR
COMMITTEE COLLEGE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
THERE'S A AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR
TO REMOVE THE CONTINGENCY CLAUSE.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TO TO AS AMENDED -- SB FIVE
TWENTY ONE INCOMING CORPORATION
TAX RENTED PROPERTY CREDITS FOR
PERSONS RECEIVING SECTION EIGHT
ASSISTANCE THERE'S A MEMBERS TO
MAKE THE CREDIT OPERATIVE ONLY
NEAR SPECIFIED.
IN A TRAILER BILL WERE STEPS TO
THE ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THAT
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ANY
UNANIMOUS SIX TO ZERO VOTE.
SB FIVE THIRTY TWO REDEVELOPMENT
CITY OF GLENDALE BOND PROCEEDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S A TO
PASS IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD
BRADFORD AYE HILL -- HILL AYE
JONES.
JON SNOW WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE -- PASSES.
FIVE TO ONE SB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING COLLEGE FOCUS RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAM.
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO ADD A CO
AUTHOR RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM
SB.
FORTY THREE AND THE BILL PASSES
FOR TWO TWO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING.
NO.
SB SIX HUNDRED HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE FERTILITY PRESERVATION
THE TO DO PASS PERCEPTION ROLL
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES FORTY TWO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SIX TWENTY CRIMINAL OFFENDER
RECORD INFORMATION REFERRAL
PERSONS ON SUPERVISED RELEASE.
WE ARE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB SIX NINETY FIVE LAND USE
PLANNING HOUSING ELEMENT FOSTER
YOUTH PLACEMENT.
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL CALL
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX ZERO THERE'S A DO PASS SB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
THE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE TO DO
PASS OPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL'S APPROVED ANY
UNANIMOUS VOTE. SIX ZERO MOVING
TO GENERAL ROTH SB FIFTY SIX
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE EXPANSION A
MAN TO MAKE CONTINUE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE FACILITY
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS
AND REMOVE THE SUPPORT COSTS.
WAS A ROLL CALL VOTE PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY HI BECAUSE HE
AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO SB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PEOPLE HEALTH TYPE
ONE DIABETES IS TO DO PASS.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL PASSES SIX ZERO SB
THREE OH SEVEN WATER CONVEYANCE
USE OF FACILITY WITH UNUSED
CAPACITY IS TO DO PASS.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
SB THREE SIXTY TWO EMPLOYMENT
UNPAID WAGES AND BENEFITS
INTERNET.
WEBSITE -- IT IS A DO PASS WERE
SUB TO THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR TWO
TWO AS BEFORE SIXTY ONE STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID CAL GRANT SUMMER
TERMS.
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES -- SUBSTRING
THE ROLE FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES SIX ZERO UNANIMOUSLY SB
FIVE FIVE FOUR ADULT SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL ADMIT STATUS
TO ENROLLMENT.
UNDER AKTION ME -- IT'S TO DO
PASS SECTION ROLE FROM SB THREE
BILLS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS VOTE --
SIX TO ZERO SB FIVE SIXTY THREE
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAYS GRANTS TO DO PASS
RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB.
THREE BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB
SIX FIVE FIVE ON PHARMACY TO DO
PASS RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX TO ZERO MOVING TO SENATOR
RUBIO SB TWO SEVENTY THREE ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS A MEMBERS
TO STRIKE.
THE EXTENSION RELATED TO
COOPERATING VICTIMS IT'S A
RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB THREE THE
BILL SPRUCE SIX ZERO AS AMENDED
SB.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES AS A TO PASS
RECEPTION TO THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL IS APROVED.
A UNANIMOUS VOTE SIX TO ZERO SB
FIVE NINETY FOUR PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION ENGLISH LEARNER ROAD
MAP INITIATIVE THERE'S
AMENDMENTS PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
THE PROGRAM CONTINGENT ON
APPROPRIATIONS PERCEPTION ROLL
CALL.
OF SB THREE THE BILL PASSES AS
AMENDED SIX TO ZERO SB SIX
FOURTEEN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION.
GRANT PROGRAM IS AMENDMENTS FOR
AUTHOR TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION
RECEPTION ROLL CALL.
SB THREE THE ROLL CALL US SO
PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB SIX AS
AMENDED SB SIX FIFTY ON USE
CANCER MEDICATIONS COLLECTION
AND DISTRIBUTION A TO DO PASS.
RECEPTION IN THE ROLL CALL FROM
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX
ZERO SB SIX SIX EIGHT FIRE
HYDRANT WATER SUPPLIERS
REGULATION THE TO DO PASS.
SUBSIDY TO ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE BILL PASSES SIX ZERO SB
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO REMOVE
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENT. TO
ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY WE CASKEY AYE.
BILL PASSES FIVE TO ONE SB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE VETERANS RENTAL
HOUSING IT'S AN TO PASS.
SECTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
THE BILL PASSES SIX TWO ZERO SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE CORPORATION TAX
EXEMPTION.
ORGANIZATIONS MUTUAL DITCH
IRRIGATION COMPANIES IS SAID TO
PASS SUB TO TO ROLL FROM SB
THREE BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PERCENTAGE OF FULL TIME
INSTRUCTIONS.
A MEMBER AUTHORED TO REDUCE THE
DISTRICT'S ANNUAL PROGRESS
REQUIREMENT MEANT TO MAKE THE
REQUIREMENT CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION.
AND IT IS SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE
FROM -- SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES.
FORTY WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW.
MOVING ON TO MISS SKINNER.
SB EIGHTEEN KEEP CALIFORNIANS
HOUSING ACT THERE'S A MEMBERS
FOR AUTHORED TO DELETE DCA
REQUIREMENTS AMENDED STRIKE.
C. E. S. H. PROGRAM PROVISIONS
AND IT IS A SUBJECT TO THE ROLL
CALL FROM IT SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL PASSES FORTY TWO AS AMENDED
WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NOW SB FORTY TWO THE
GETTING HOME SAY FACT THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO STRIKE THE
ONLINE POSTING REQUIREMENT. TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO AMEND
THE STRIKE. TO STRIKE THE
TRANSPORTATION PROVISIONS IT IS
SUBSTRING ROLL CALL FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB FORTY FOR MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES COMPTON
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY IT'S A DO
PASS RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB FORTY NINE ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
GOD TO DO PASS RECEPTION ROLE
FROM SB FORTY THREE WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOTE PASSAGE.
FORTY TWO SB TWO OH SIX COLLEGE
ATHLETICS FAIR HEY TO PLAY ACT
FOR AMENDING TO DELAY THE BILL'S
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND ADD CO
AUTHORS -- WERE SENT TO THE ROLE
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL
PASSES FOR TO TO WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
SB THREE TEN JURY SELECTION
AMEND TO STRIKE THE DATA
COLLECTION REQUIREMENT TO CLEAN
INCLUDE AN EXPANDED PRESUMPTION.
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE -- FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES.
FOR TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW SB THREE THIRTY
HOUSING CRISIS ACTIVE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO REDUCE THE OPERATIVE
PERIOD OF FIVE YEARS AND
ELIMINATE.
PROHIBITION AGAINST CHARGING
DEVELOPER FEES.
RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO TWO AS AMENDED.
SB THREE THREE SEVEN CHILD
SUPPORT THERE'S A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR REDUCE PASTOR FROM 1100%
TO THE FEDERAL LIMIT PERCEPTION
ROLL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES. SIX TO ZERO AS AMENDED
AS BEFORE SEVENTY ELECTRONIC
BENEFITS TRANSFER SYSTEM THERE'S
A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR REQUIRED DE
SS TO ESTABLISH PROTOCOLS TO
BLOCK RETAILERS.
AND TO MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING CHANGES RECEPTION
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
AS AMENDED PASSES. SIX TWO ZERO
MOVING TO SENATOR STERN SB ONE
TWENTY FIREARMS PROHIBITED
PERSONS -- IT'S A DO PASS FOR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
AS BEFORE SIXTY TWO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PORCELAIN RESTORATION
WORK FORCE PROGRAM IT TO DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB THREE
IT PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB FOUR
SIXTY THREE NATURAL GAS STORAGE
WELLS MONITORING REPORTING.
IT TO DO PASS SUBSIDIES THE ROLE
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES
SIX TO ZERO SB FOUR SEVENTY ONE
SUBPOENAS FOREMAN SERVICES TO DO
PASS.
RECEPTION ROLL CALL OFF FROM SB
THREE THE BILL PASSES SIX ZERO
SB FOUR SEVEN FOR CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE PROTECTION ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND.
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON AN APPROPRIATION
PERCEPTION ROLL FROM SB.
THREE BILL PASSES SIX TO ZERO SB
FIVE FOUR TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION IT'S A TO PASS.
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.%
JONES I WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TWO ZERO SB
SIX THIRTEEN STATE AGENCY
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTION REPORT TO DO PASS.
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TWO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW
CORPORATIONS MINIMUM FRANCHISE
TAX EXEMPTION ARMED FORCES IS TO
DO PASS RECEPTION ROLL CALL FOR
BEST BE.
THREE BILL PASSES. SIX ZERO SB
SIX THREE THREE SANTA SUSANA
FIELD LABORATORY MONITORING
PROGRAMS.
SUBSTANTIVE RIGHTS TO DO PASS
RECEPTION ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY SIX TO ZERO SB THREE
SIX TO ME.
SIX THREE SIX ELECTIONS BALLOT
LABEL THERE'S A MEMBERS PER
AUTHOR TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO I'M PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY HI WE CASKEY
AYE [inaudible]
THE ONE BILL PASSES FOUR TO ONE
SB SEVEN THIRTY COMMISSION ON
FUTURE OF WORK IS A MEMBERS TO
INCORPORATE THE COMMISSION ON
TECH EQUITY.
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS PASSED SIX TO
ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR ELECTRIC
ELECTRICITY MICROBEADS TO TO DO
PASS PERCEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES FOR
TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER OMNIBUS BILL -- IT TO
DO PASS RECEPTION IN THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES. SIX TWO ZERO MOVINGON
TO MISTER STONE SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR PROPERTY TAXATION SENIOR IN
DISABILITY DISABLED VETERANS
THERE'S A MEMBERS TO REMOVE THE
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION AND WE'RE
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
THREE THE BILL PASSES AS AMENDED.
SIX TO ZERO THAT'S BEFORE TWELVE
DEVELOPMENT OF SERVICE FEES.
THE BILL.
IS TO DO PASSAGE.
RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB THREE THE
BILL PASSES SIX ZERO SB FIVE
NINETY MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATIONS
GRAVELY DISABLED DUE TO
IMPAIRMENT.
OF CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM IS TO DO
PASS RECEPTION IN THE ROLE FOR
SB THREE THE BILL PASSES. SIX
ZERO SB SIX EIGHTEEN PEACE
OFFICERS PERJURY IT'S A DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
SIX TO ZERO ABOUT MOVING TO MR
UMBERG -- SB SEVENTY TWO
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS IS A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR TO ADD CO AUTHORS.
OR SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES
FORTY TWO WAS REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW.
SB THREE NINETY SCHOOL SECURITY
OFFICERS AND GUARDS MEMBERS PER
AUTHORED WISHED APERTURE PHASE
IN PERIOD TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
TO ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BRADFORD BRADFORD I HELD.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY AYE.
THE BILL PASSES FIVE TWO ZERO SB
FIVE SEVENTY SIX STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY -- MEMBERS TO
ELIMINATE INTERNATIONAL
CONVENTION REQUIREMENTS AS A
ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
RIGHT BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
WE CASKEY I THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE TO ONE SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX
CREATIVE ECONOMY TASK FORCES TO
DO PASS SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES.
SIX ZERO MOVING ON TO MISTER
WHITE KOWSKI -- SB THIRTEEN
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS THERE'S
A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR FOR HAVE
BEEN ENFORCEMENT OUT SUB
STANDARD EIGHTY USE FOR FIVE
YEARS AND MAKING CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
WHITE HOUSE YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION.
WE ARE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL WAS
APPROVED ANY UNANIMOUS. SIX TO
ZERO VOTE SB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE KLAY.
CHIEF CLIMATE RESILIENCY OFFICER
THERE'S A MEMBERS REQUIRE SENATE
CONFIRMATION FOR THE NEW
POSITION SENATE ROLL CALL FROM
SB FORTY THREE WILL BE
SUBSTITUTED THE BILL PASSES.
FORTY TWO WAS REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW.
JUST BEFORE THIRTY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT BENEFITS
JUDGES A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
SPECIFY.
THE BILL WOULD APPLY
PROSPECTIVELY WE ARE SUBSTANTIVE
ROLE FROM SB THREE THE BILL
PASSES AS AMENDED SIX TO ZERO AS
BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN PERSONAL
INCOME TAXES CREDITS.
DEDUCTION QUALIFIED EDUCATION
LOAN THERE'S A MEMONS TO MAKE
THE CREDIT OPERATIVE ONLY IN
YOUR SPECIFIED IN A TRAILER BILL.
AND WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB THREE THE BILL PASSES AS
AMENDED SIX ZERO PUBLIC GROUP BY
SB FIVE EIGHTEEN PUBLIC RECORDS
DISCLOSE COURT COSTS AND
ATTORNEYS FEES IS TO TO PASS.
AND IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES NO BATES NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
BECAUSE K <c.cyan>WI.</c>
THE BILL WAS OUT.
FOR TWO MOVING ON TO SENATOR
WIENER.
SB TWENTY THREE UNLAWFUL ENTRY
OF A VEHICLE THERE'S A MEMBERS
PER AUTHOR DEFINE TO DEFINE.
FORCIBLE ENTRY PERCEPTION IN THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BIL
IS OUT SIX ZERO AS AMENDED SB
THIRTY FOUR CANNABIS DONATIONS --
IT'S A DO PASS OR SUB TO THE
ROLL CALL FROM SB THREE THE BILL
IS OUT. SIX ZERO SB FORTY
CONSERVATORSHIP SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS -- IT'S A DO PASS AND
THE SUB TO THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS OUT. SIX ZERO
SB FIFTY EIGHT ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
HOURS OF SALE.
IT IS A DO PASS AND WE TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES NO BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL WAS OUT.
FIVE TWO ONE SB SIXTY NINE OCEAN
RESILIENCY ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AMEND PER AUTHOR TO
DELETE VARIOUS ADVISER GROUPS
AND ASSESSMENT RAN.
DELETE SPECIFIED WATER BOARD
REQUIREMENTS IN.
ACT AQUACULTURE REPORT AND IT'S
A ROLL CALL VOTE.
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE KOWSKI HI BECAUSE HE
I THE BILL IS OUT.
FOUR TO ONE I SB ONE TWENTY
SEVEN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
COMPLETE STREETS THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHORED TO CHANGE A
DIVISION OF ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION WOULD DEPARTMENT.
BRANCH PRIORITIZE EXPENDITURES
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND CLARIFY APPLICABILITY -- WE
ARE GOING TO SUBSIDIZE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL WAS OUT FORTY TWO AS
AMENDED WITH REPUBLICANS.
VOTING NO SB ONE THIRTY TWO
CORRECTIONS THERE'S A MEMBERS TO
STRIKE A SPECIFIED IN TAKE
QUESTION SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM SB FORTY THREE THE
BILL IS OUT.
FORTY TWO AS AMENDED WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW SB ONE
FORTY TWO EMPLOYEES LACTATION
ACCOMMODATION TO DO PASS
RECEPTION THE ROLL CALL FROM SB
FORTY THREE THE BILL PASSES. FOR
TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NOW SB ONE FORTY FIVE SEX
OFFENDERS REGISTRATION MEMBERS
PER AUTHORED TO REPLACE THE
PETITION PROCESS.
THE WE'RE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB FORTY THREE THE BILL IS
OUT.
FOR TO TO WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NOW AS IT'S AS AMENDED.
SB ONE FIFTY NINE H. I. B. PRE
EXPOSURE IN POST EXPOSURE FOR
PROPHYLACTIC PROPHYLAXIS.
AMEND PER AUTHOR TO ADD CO
AUTHORS EXPAND STAKEHOLDERS CON
CONSULTATION.
IT'S A ROLL CALL VOTE ON SB ONE
FIFTY NINE AS AMENDED PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HELL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES NO WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
BILL WAS OUT FOR A ONE SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT CAL WORKS
ELIGIBILITY ASSIST LIMITATIONS
TO TO DO PASS.
RECEPTION THE ROLE FROM SB FORTY
THREE THE BILL IS OUT FORTY TWO
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NOW.
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES MEN'S PER AUTHOR
DISARMING THE FEASIBILITY OR
OTHER BENEFITS PROGRAMS USE CAL
SAWS AND TO REMOVE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION.
INTERFACE RECEPTION ROLE FROM SB
THREE THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO
ZERO AS AMENDED.
SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT ELECTRICITY
RENEWABLE RESOURCE SELF
GENERATION AND STORAGE THERE'S A
MEMBERS TO DELETE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AN ACTIVE
ACTIVITIES RELATED.
DISTRIBUTION ENERGY RESOURCES OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB --
FORTY THREE SB TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
IS OUT FORTY TWO AS AMENDED WITH
REPUBLICANS FLOATING NOW.
SB FIVE NINETY TWO STATE PORTER
BARBERING IN COSMETOLOGY LICENSE
INFORMATION -- IT'S A DO PASS OR
SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE FROM SB --
THREE SO THE BILL IS OUT
SIX ZERO MOVING ON TO SENATOR
WILK.
SB ONE FIFTY THREE INDUSTRIAL
HEMP THERE'S A MEMBERS FOR
AUTHOR TO ADD A AUTHORS. THREE
IS OUT THE RECEPTION ROLE SIT
FROM SB THREE SO SB ONE FIFTY
THREE IS OUT SIX TO ZERO AS
AMENDED SB TWO NINETEEN FOSTER
YOUTH ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES.
MEN'S PER AUTHOR TO CAP THE
PROGRAM AT TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION RECEPTIONIST ROLE FROM
SB THREE SO THE BILL IS OUT AS
AMENDED.
SIX TO ZERO SB THREE THREE THREE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCIAL COUNCIL STORAGE PLAN
THERE'S A MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO
ADD A CO AUTHOR.
RECEPTION ROLE FROM ESPRIT THE
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO AS
AMENDED.
SB FIVE EIGHTY ANIMAL ABUSE PRO
PATIENT TREATMENT THERE'S A
MEMBERS PER AUTHOR TO PROHIBIT
THE RELEASE OF PROGRESS REPORTS
WITHOUT THE DEFENDANT'S CONSENT
AND WE ARE SUBSTITUTING THE ROLE
FROM SB.
THREE THE BILL IS OUT -- SIX
ZERO HOLD ON ONE SECOND
[inaudible]
CHAU.
OKAY SO WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO SB.
SEVENTY I NEED A MOTION WE
FORGOT THE BILL IS TO BE
APPROVED WITH AMENDMENTS.
SO WE HAVE TO RECONSIDER THE
INTENSITY SEVENTY BY MR NIELSEN.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO RECONSIDER
THE VOTE ON SB.
SEVENTY WE'LL FIND IT FOR
SOARING HOME ON
YES SO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO RECONSIDER.
ON SB SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
PORTANTINO NINE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HILL HILL I JONES.
JONES I WE COUNTY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
THE BILL WAS RECONSIDERED AND SO
NOW I NEED A MOTION IT IS COURT
THE MET THE MOTION IS. TO DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION AND CAN WE
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FROM SB.
THREE AND MAKE IT A SIX ZERO
WITHOUT OBJECTION MUCH WE'RE
GONNA DO SO SB SEVENTY AS
AMENDED PASSES SIX ZERO
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS.
WITH THAT I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY OTHER BUSINESS RIGHT TEAM.
GOOD JOB EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION AND EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU STAFF.
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD.
MEETING ADJOURNED